foreign
[Music]
apologies I do have covid right now
which is why I can't join you in in
person and so I am ingested and I will
try not to cough into the mic and I'll
speak fully and as loudly as I can
so
I wanted to show you or talk about the
breadth of what spec can do and support
because it is getting quite complex and
that's one of my favorite things to do
at conference is talk about
what you're doing with an act uh what
workflows you're building out what
things you're creating
and
this diagram just represents some of
what those things could be but
interacting with connect should be quite
simple
um it shouldn't be complex essentially
what you're doing is creating something
in r or python they're publishing that
thing to connect and then you're letting
connect take over it executing that
thing for you and whoever else you share
that thing with does this sit on connect
under the hood connect allows you to do
some really cool stuff you can run
multiple versions of R and python you
can now run multiple versions of Porto
as well on the single server and your
applications your documents your apis
everything that you create and publish
to connect all of those things are
sandboxed apart from one another so that
you can run those different versions of
packages for all of your content
fundamentally though if you're using
connect today
all of the content you published there
all of it runs using these local
processes on the same host or container
as the connect server
and that's why I want to draw your
attention to because this talk is what
comes next or connect here it's about
our next Evolution for Content execution
and our story there
So today we're really excited to
announce off post content execution for
connect on kubernetes this feature will
be in beta for now but if you are a
connect admin we would love for you to
give it a try
beta means in a bit let's let's talk
about
what this means for you
so in this world when you're running
office content execution
now instead of using local processes to
run all of your content items in the
same place
kubernetes is used to execute your
content and all of your jobs are
external to The Container that's running
that connect server
so I want to pause here and make sure
that if you are a data scientist or a
connect publisher in the audience today
uh you should know that I I am not here
to tell you that you need to run home
and learn how to containerize your
applications or teach yourself
kubernetes our goal is not to take away
the simple
of that publishing user experience like
I talked about at the beginning of this
presentation
in fact the publishing user experience
should not change remarkably so if you
are running office content execution so
instead of tell you let me show you what
that looks like
if you come over here to the
documentation page
in the connect dashboard and you scroll
down to where you used to see all of the
versions of our python Corto that are
available on your server if you're
running office execution you'll now see
a list or a set of execution images
and these are going to show you the
options that you have as a publisher
for what sorts of environments that can
be used to build and execute your
content
you can choose to Target a specific one
of these images if you're publishing or
you can let connect just stick for you
it has a version mapping algorithm just
like it could for you when you do
publishing today
can you still hear me
I guess nobody's there to respond never
mind I'll keep going we can sorry okay
great thank you
foreign
through a quick get back publishing demo
here just to show you what this looks
like from the user experience
perspective and get pop publishing
um in addition to all the other
publishing methods they this really
shouldn't change very much
so I'm going to grab a URL here
wrap it in
this is my repo I'm going to select a
branch
and then get select the
application in my repo that I want give
it a title app one
and when I hit deploy again because I
haven't uh
specifically told connect which
execution image that I want to use to
build and execute this piece of content
it's it's just going to find one that
runs
r41 for me so they open it up here
I will be able to see my content item
and it will use that same execution
image now you will notice a little bit
of delay here when you launch an
application in office execution mode
and some of that has to do maybe
sometimes with pulling down that
execution image but a lot of the cost is
wrapped up in job spotting and process
startup so there is a little bit more of
a delay but again if you wanted to work
around that you have the same tools as
you do with local execution where you
can set the minimum processes you want
to have one always available if this is
a particularly important app that needs
to come up very quickly for your users
now let's see which content execution
image can actually picked for me
and uh pump up here so you can see
scroll down you'll see you have a new
piece of metadata here at the bottom of
the content info Pane and this just
lists
the image that got used for our last
execution
if I wasn't intending to Target that
image then I would need to go back and
regenerate the Manifest file and specify
a new image parameter and this is all
described in the user guide here so you
can see how you can add
the image that you're looking for
specifically
if you are generating a manifest but you
can also use the deploy app play API to
play Doctor play site functions from
rsconnect and similar functions exist
for RS connect python as well
if there isn't an image that matches the
version of our python that you need
you'll get the same type of deployment
error as you would today using local
execution
um
with local processes if there isn't a
version of our python on your server
that's available
all right so hopefully
that has reasonably convinced you that
the user experience isn't going to
change remarkably although you can now
Target images if you want to do that we
don't yet have support for a push button
in uh publishing or targeting specific
images but that is on our roadmap so
look out for that if you're interested
all right
so now that I've gone through that I
want to switch gears and talk more
directly to maybe the administrator
Persona about what this looks like
so let's talk about host execution from
that angle
now if you are an admin you should know
that this functionality uses the same
components if you're familiar with the
rstudio workbench product and it's your
job launcher
we're using that that same Paradigm but
bundling it with that so if you want to
run off those specification with connect
you're going to need to use a version of
connect that has the job launcher
bundled with it so I recommend starting
with the latest release of connect which
is our July Edition that went out last
week in addition to that you're going to
need to have as always a valid connect
license and then database and that'll be
postgres for this case and then some
shared file storage could be NFS or EFS
anything that's read write many
on the kubernetes requirement side
you're going to need of course a working
kubernetes cluster and then you the the
kubernetes command line tool and also
Helm version 3 which
is the package manager for kubernetes in
this case
if you have all of those things you're
basically set up to go at this point and
we have documentation for how to run
through install and configure to get all
the way to this point but
um I've shown a lot of architecture
diagrams at this point and they're kind
of not the best way to illustrate all of
this so because I'm remote and nobody is
here to stop me uh I thought it would be
cool just to do a speed run installation
of all of this see how far we can get
uh and
show you just how fast and easy it is to
get up and running hopefully that will
be what happens it will be faster music
I have cheated a little as always as any
good Speed Run installation does I've
already set up my kubernetes cluster
it nodes
where they are they're ready to go
uh and I've already set some environment
variables I set up my rstudio connect
license key so that you can't see that
that's my key and then I've also created
a database password for my my postgres
database I have the kubernetes s full
two pedal tube CTL whatever it's called
there installed and Helm that's all set
up
and in this next section we will Helm
install all the things this is really
just
a talk subtitled a love letter to helm
and Helm is is really awesome and and
we're excited to be able to install
everything this way because it makes the
installation so simple it makes a
repeatable you can update you can roll
back and sort of stage your deployment
and I'll show you what some of that
looks like here clear
and the first thing we'll need to do is
pull down a bunch of Helm charts in
order to do that and update the home
repos so we provide a chart for
installing our studio connect here to
grab that in addition to the one for
postgres and NFS and it will update the
repo the postgres and NFS chart are just
sort of for illustrative purposes we're
assuming that most folks are going to
bring their own so stress and NFS or EFS
and we write many shared storage
but if you didn't have anything like
that or if you're doing the same sort of
Speed Run installation that I'm doing
here you can use these to get up and
running really fast all right so we've
got all our chart
good to go and the next thing we're
going to do is create a namespace to
install everything issue this will just
keep everything nice and sandbox and
tidy
I'm gonna call this uh work this game
Space rstudio connect
and once we have that
and we switched into it
we can now start Helm installing things
so the first one I'll Helm install
a postgres chat I'm actually using this
Helm upgrade install command which I
just learned a couple weeks ago it's
really cool because you can just run the
same thing over and over again and it
upgrades it if it already exists it
installs it if it doesn't
I'm gonna do the same with my NFS server
provisional charts
and that
all right now
if I'm done everything correct should be
able to get some parts
awesome so I've got my NFS creating my
postgres is running and I'm good to go
it's
make sure that comes up
oh cool
all right now we're on to the connect
installation this is the meat of it here
so if you wanted to look at all of the
default values that come with the
rstudio connect home chart
you can do a Helm show values
on the connect chart and that'll just
give you the whole list there's quite a
lot
I'm going to go ahead and skip that what
we're going to do is overwrite some of
those default values with a
values.yaml file so let's create that
new file
and this first part is going to set the
replicas and then I'm going to configure
shared storage here grab all that
dump that in Connect needs shared
storage needs to be mounted in
um you need to create a persistent
volume claim and give it a name here and
this name is arbitrary that used in a
couple places here so make sure if you
change that that you change it in all
the places that it needs to be changed
and you're going to create a storage
class or NFS
about how much storage you're requesting
and then finally
enable the launcher and that all there
is
do it
so if I save out here and I'll use that
animal
save
D all right now I am good to go
and from here uh sort of your process
for using Helm is to change this
values.yaml file and then run this
command here
um template the chart with your values
found
and this sort of pattern updating your
values animal and then checking it on
Helm template will show you like how
your value style affects the template
and that's sort of like what my uh my
buddy Cole and Helm wizard calls the
bread and butter of using Helm this is
sort of the power and it's also going to
be really useful as we interact with you
because you can send us your value saml
file and then we at our studio on the
support side can run this same home
template command and see exactly what
you're saying to see how your value saml
file is going to interact with the
template
so that's really useful the other
section that we're going to want to add
to this values animal file is some
configuration for connect itself so this
is where the things that you would
traditionally put in your go
configuration file are going to get
dumped instead so add that
and you'll see that we are adding a
database configuration we're saying it's
going to be postgres and that'll
overwrite the default of SQL Lite I'm
going to give it an address again if
you're using the connect namespace the
rstudio dash connect namespace that URL
should be correct and then uh
you're just going to provide the same
persistent volume claim name or this new
section of configuration for connect
launcher and that should match what you
had up here right so let's save that out
and now
if I did everything correct we should be
able to helm install next
let's give it a shot
installing it now
ads
that's creating yes you're just out of
time unfortunately
oh sorry
uh okay thank you yeah if you can wrap
up in like 30 seconds if you have the
final thoughts as we sort of switch over
um there's a couple of questions I saw
folk test on slido please ask those at
the open source Lounge
um
and let's give Kelly a hand for the talk
yeah
thanks
um I wanted to say thank you to the team
for sure and this this project has come
together over a while by a number of
folks at our studio but the core team as
it is today I want to say
congratulations to Aaron and Bill China
Chris Cole David and Jill and thank you
to all of the folks who helped us out
during the private beta over the last
year that's been really great so thank
you
foreign
[Music]